acabamos de completar unos vídeos sobre
el teorema del binomio pues pienso que
ahora ya que los hemos terminado podemos
hacer la prueba de la derivada de la
forma general de las potencias de x esto
es tomar la derivada de x a la n ahora
ya que sabemos el teorema del binomio
tenemos las herramientas para poder
hacerlo como lo hacemos bueno empecemos
con la definición clásica de derivada
esto es el límite cuando delta x se
aproxima a 0 de la función evaluada en x
+ delta x - efe x entre delta x cierto
entonces f x en este caso es x + delta x
a la n menos la función evaluada en x
que es x a la n iv todo eso sobre delta
x
ahora sabiendo el teorema del binomio
podemos desarrollar esta expresión la
expresión x + delta x a la n si no sabes
el teorema del binomio visita los otros
vídeos en la lista de reproducción de
pre cálculo y pon el vídeo del teorema
del binomio por el teorema del binomio
vamos a escribirlo acá abajo el límite
cuando delta x tiende a cero solo
estamos copiando lo que tenemos acá
arriba desarrollando lo anterior nos va
a dar x a la n x a la n más las
combinaciones de n en 1
en 1
de nuevo revisa el teorema del binomio
si es que esto te parece un poco extraño
las combinaciones de n en uno por equis
a la n menos uno por delta x
ahora como tercer término vamos a tener
las combinaciones de n en 2 en el 2 x x
a la n 2
por delta x al cuadrado
luego tendremos más y más sumandos y
esos sumándose están dados por el
teorema del binomio ahora por supuesto
el último dígito que vamos a agregar
será 1 por bueno en realidad serían las
combinaciones de n en n
ok cnn por equis a la 0 que en realidad
es uno por delta equis a la n
esa es la expansión del teorema del
binomio ahora volvamos a la parte
amarilla lo único que nos falta es
restar del lado derecho x a la n
ok y todo eso dividirlo sobre delta x
sobre delta x vamos a ver qué tanto
podemos simplificar lo primero notemos
que tenemos estos dos x a la n que se
pueden cancelar muy bien y ahora si nos
fijamos en todos los términos de arriba
notemos que tienen un factor delta x el
cual podemos dividirlo entre el delta x
que tenemos en el denominador esto será
lo mismo entonces que vamos a escribirlo
completo que el límite
límite cuando delta x se aproxima a cero
ok lo que vamos a hacer es dividir la
parte del numerador entre el delta x del
denominador lo cual nos da n
combinaciones en uno por x a la n menos
uno por delta x sobre delta equis que es
simplemente uno más n combinaciones en 2
por equis a la n 2 por delta x al
cuadrado entre delta x lo cual nos da
simplemente un delta x de este lado y
así tendremos la división de varios
sumandos de la parte de arriba entre
delta equis y finalmente lo que nos
queda será n combinaciones en n
n combinaciones nn por equis a la 0 que
son así que no vamos a prestarle
atención por delta x a la n 1 que es
delta x a la n entre delta x
entonces qué hacemos ahora ahora tomamos
el límite cuando delta x tiende a cero
como delta x tiende a cero entonces cada
uno de los sumandos que tienen como
factor a delta x van a hacerse 0 y el
único que no va a desaparecer en esta
suma será el primer término si todos
esos sumandos nos dan ceros y nos
quedamos únicamente con este primer
término entonces lo que nos queda es lo
siguiente las combinaciones de n en 1
por x a la n 1 y quién es eso cuáles son
las combinaciones de en en uno bueno eso
es n factorial entre 1 factorial x enee
menos 1 factorial ok eso lo
multiplicamos por x al n menos 1 ahora 1
factorial es 1 y n factorial entre n
menos 1 factorial bueno piénsalo de esta
forma 7 factorial entre 6 factorial nos
da 7 10 factorial entre 9 factorial nos
da 10
n factorial dividido entre n menos uno
factorial en realidad sólo es n y esto
lo va a multiplicar a x a la n 1 y ya
está la fórmula de la derivada de x a la
n simplemente es n por x a la n 1 solo
demostramos la derivada de cualquier
número entero como potencias aunque la x
puede ser cualquier número real
después veremos que realmente funciona
para cualquier número real los números y
el exponente por supuesto bueno nos
vemos en un próximo vídeo bueno no antes
que eso quería señalar una cosa y es que
yo les había dicho que necesitabas
conocer el teorema del binomio para
poder desarrollar esta prueba y no es
tanto así si pudiste darte cuenta sólo
necesitábamos algunos términos de ese
desarrollo por ejemplo a más b a la n en
realidad es a la n más n veces a a la n
1 por b más una serie de sumandos que
para fines de esta prueba no fueron
necesarios porque eso se hicieron 0
cuando hicimos tender el límite de delta
x aproximándose a cero así que si esto
bueno te confunde no no lo tomes en
cuenta sólo estoy diciendo que podríamos
acabar el resto de la prueba sólo
conociendo los primeros dos términos del
teorema del vino
nos vemos en próximos vídeos